[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Planet Costa
College today I'll be taking a look at a
coaster known as the crazy one or loony
turns in game but in real life it's
usually called an El loco and excuse my
language but these things are definitely
very local coasters and sometimes also
called wild mouse on crack since they
are very small compact and cheap to
build but still features some unique
elements that you normally don't really
see on roller coasters like some of the
steepest drops in the world
some inversions that feature a lot of
hang time and curves that are very tight
and even Bank outward there are about
six of these in the world and most of
them feature a very similar layout with
some minor changes and I do want to get
away from that a little bit in this
tutorial but still show you all of the
basic elements of these coasters and
hiking at creatively yourself with these
now as per usual I want to raise up my
station a little bit not too much but
just enough to get going before we get
into the little because I want this
thing to curve around a bit before the
little it's not necessary to do it for
this type but in this case because I
want to make a very compact coaster it
is something that will definitely come
in handy and I want to get into the lift
hill with about three curving pieces and
a very very minor slope just enough to
get the car going and what I can usually
do for this is to build this piece like
this then remove it to an off angle snap
and move the piece down a little bit
there we go and now we should have a
nice little slope in there alright now
it's time to make the lift hill and
since these things are so small they
usually also have a very steep little
and while I don't have an exact number
on this somewhere around 50 degrees
seems just about rights in terms of the
size and realism of these coasters so
that's usually what I go for and we want
to build this thing up to a height of
about 30 meters it can definitely be a
little bit larger if you want to make a
slightly larger el loco or maybe a bit
smaller if you want to make a minor
version but somewhere around that
Heights is just about what we're looking
for
oh and quick side note by the way that
means a
about 100 feet if I remember correctly
if you're not using the metric system
and after that what these things often
do is they curve around for a little bit
but it wouldn't be an el loco if it
didn't do that in a kind of local way so
we're going to first go down just a tad
just to get some speed and after that
we're going to curve into a completely
different direction then you were
probably expecting and go in here and
after that's kind of finished the s-band
in the other direction and have a very
very tight curve back into the direction
which we came from now this is where
it's going to get interesting because
we're going into the first drop of the
coaster here so I want to make that
beyond vertical drop and make that quite
small because what we're doing here is
we're putting some trim brakes over the
first drop to hold down the speed a
little bit make sure that it's not going
over that too quickly and then we want
to go beyond vertical and the amount
that you're going beyond vertical over
here doesn't really matter too much it
can really range from 110 to 120 degrees
but just as long as you have a crazy
drop which is going beyond vertical you
should be fine and you do want to hold
those trims just a little bit as you're
going into the beyond vertical part now
that we're done with that we can release
the trims and bring the coarser track
back into the ground and when it comes
to the shaping of the drop all that you
really want to make sure is that the top
curve is very small and has those trim
breaks around it and then we have a very
smooth gliding kind of curve back down
into the ground now once I'm on the
other side I want to try and get over
the little over here to try and conserve
as much space as I can and this is what
usually these things do in real life as
well but one thing to be very careful
about is the fact that these streams
over here make sure that the coaster
starts making speed from about this
point so we don't want to be getting too
high on this side and we want to make
sure that the track stays low enough
that the coaster car can actually clear
it now of course I'm a little bit
paranoid about the coaster actually
making this so I want to start a test
over here and while I'm doing that just
happily build away at the curve that I'm
making here
and this is something which you don't
normally have at this stage of the ride
in El locos but it's something that you
pretty much always have in our locos
it's an upward banked curve we want to
make sure that it doesn't take this
curve with a lot of speed and just kind
of throws you out of the seat in the
curve but not too much so we're going to
have to be very careful with the speed
there but as the car is making its way
into the testing zone there I want to
have some block breaks over here because
these are of course poses with very
small trains and we want to make sure
that we can fit a good number of trains
on the different blocks in the coaster
and there we go that seems like just
about a decent drop speed is actually
quite good on that curve as well so I'm
very happy with that
and all that's really still left to do
and this is something which you do
definitely need on el loco since they're
very small coasters and very hard to get
smooth is smooth out the parts of the
track quite well and especially here and
there where it's still looking wonky I
want to smooth out these parts
individually there we go
it also kind of takes up the banking so
I'm a little bit worried about that but
I haven't smooth the entire thing here
yet so I want to quickly do that as well
make sure everything is as smooth as I
can and yeah I could definitely Bank
that out a little bit again smoothing
tool does like to get rid of some of
your banking sometimes what I usually do
is just select the unbanked section and
smooth it out one last time there we go
and that looks just about decent a
little bit painful maybe on that
transition but you know it's it's a
crazy kind of coaster at this point of
the right they usually feature some
outward banked curves into a dive loop
and I want to do something similar to
that but because I already have the
outward banked curve here I'm just going
to slightly bend my way toward the dive
loop something which you might notice
here is that I turned on my banking
offsets to make sure that these curves
are a little bit more smooth which you
definitely want to make sure with some
curves which I actually banked the right
direction just so it makes them a little
bit more smooth
there we go and because I'm coming out
of the block brakes I do want to go down
a little bit not too much so just about
that should be fine and as always I'm
not really too worried about the
smoothness of the track yet usually I
just kind of lay out where I want my
track to go and then use the smoothing
tool to make the final shaping of the
track correct so here I'm going to start
making that dive loop section and what
these things very often do in their dive
loops is feature crazy ridiculous hang
time so I will just let it hang upside
down for a little bit over here and it's
gonna pass through that quite slowly yup
and then we're basically going to go
down let's see how that works and with
some slightly smoother pieces along the
bottom that should be just about it for
the dive loop you can definitely already
tell that this thing is already quite a
bit more spaced out than a regular el
loco which are yeah usually even more
compact than this I would say but still
these are really some of the typical
elements that you'll find and especially
around here you should be getting some
pretty nice hang time as the coaster is
coming around the corner here getting
into that twist and hanging upside down
for quite a bit there beautiful great so
we've gone down and it's time to go up
again and go to a slightly lower section
than last block break and insert another
block break over here and that's really
starting to shape up like an El loco
especially with those supports sticking
out everywhere and smooth out this hill
of course some of these hills are really
some of the easiest things to make
smooth and you can really just select an
entire thing at a time to make sure that
it's as smooth as possible and it does
go through it with a pretty good speed
one happy with that so now I think it's
time for a section in which you also
quite often see on these things but only
after we have another outward banked
curve because we might as well there are
usually not that many of these on one of
these coasters they are kind of a
gimmick but in this case I do need
a large curve so this will actually come
in quite handy and again since these are
banks in a super strange fashion I do
want them to be quite large and spread
out and not too painful and then over
here I want to get into something quite
interesting and it should be yeah there
we go it should be going through the
supports while keeping the remaining
points of the supports intact so we're
reusing the support structure there
which is quite handy and we're going to
make a barrel roll that actually goes
down to quite often see on these things
and just to make sure that we're
maintaining speed and actually want to
start moving down here and basically
twist the track 90 degrees per piece it
takes a bit of puzzling to get it right
exactly but what we want to go for is
that the roll is going to end just
before it starts evening out toward the
ground again and that's basically
something like this over here it might
look very stupid right now but this will
definitely be quite smooth in the end so
this should work and we want to even
that out at the end always watch out
with these roll star with smoothing and
all at once because as you can see
that's going to completely ruin your
roll so usually what I do is select a
couple of pieces at a time make sure
that these are all smooth and after
that's the entire track of section did I
just say track of section ah hum the
entire section of the track should be
more or less smooth enough to go there
we go and let's take all the outward
banks curve for a little bit because it
is looking very awkward they're as weird
as these things are they do have a
reputation for being super smooth and
while I've never been on one it's
definitely a life goal to do it once and
from what I've seen and read and heard
from a lot of people they're actually
really great coasters for the size that
they have alright so we're going down
somewhat smoothly there one thing to
note about planet coaster though is that
there's no continuous roll so it's
practically impossible to make barrel
rolls that are custom like this
completely smooth and really this is
just about as smooth as you can get you
might be able to get a bit more
smoothness out of it with some
trial and error but there's not that
much more in there but anyway we now
have a bit of an issue because what I
would usually recommend with these and
logos is to really get them as compact
as you can and try for the lower areas
of your track because the coaster only
dips down to the ground a few times
earlier try to get the lower areas right
underneath the toilet area so what I
just try to do is to get a over-banked
turn into this space here if that makes
any sense it's very narrow right
underneath the rest of the coaster but
that ended up removing a lot of my
supports and being very small and
crammed and not exactly what I was
looking for so in this case I'll
actually move out from the very busy
area of the coaster itself but it's not
something that I would always recommend
you do because it does space out the
coaster a little bit more and make them
less compact and it can be but in this
case I think it's just going to be the
best looking kind of option to consider
here so what I'm going to do is build a
over-banked could over-banked curve as
you very often see them on these things
they're not technically over-banked
since they don't bank beyond 90 degrees
but a it's the general idea so I just
want to make a small hill like this and
gradually go to 90 degrees as we also go
to a 90 degree curve at the top and we
go for a straight section of track and
Bank it about 90 degrees there and do
the same on the other side there we go
let's see it passing by for a little bit
to just check on the speed not sure if
that shaping is really any good but
especially with these over banked curves
or curves that look like it
they'll sometimes end up looking very
shitty when you've just built them but
as soon as you go over it with a
smoothing tool it should be more or less
okay that's just about the speed that
we're looking for so that's quite good I
do want to bank it a little bit more
here to get back into the station and I
think that'll work
let's move it out and make it look a
little bit better
now we go that's already tones better
and just to make the shape in a little
bit nicer I want to do it like this
and smooth out the individual parts
there we go that's quite good now since
we're very close to the station I
actually want to finish the brake run
before we've actually connect both parts
of the track so I'm gonna have a very
very slight incline here but my last
block brake here to make sure that we
can run as many trains as we can and
have some brakes that slow it down a
little bit at the end and finally and
this is a bit of a an interesting quirk
of these coasters some trim breaks that
cover the very small hill that is the
final hero of the coaster which we very
often see on these things and that
should more or less finish it this is
just going to make sure that once it
gets it over this hill it's already
going to break a little bit on the top
of this and not just barrage into the
final brake run and a ridiculous speed
so let's see how this is going to work
all right now the pieces are finally
fitting here and just in time for the
coaster to make its run so I'm just
gonna quickly look at it off right and
then give you an on-ride of the coaster
now I have to say this is really a
general idea of what the unlocker
courses are like it's a bit different
from the standard model it's actually
very different from the standard model
but this is usually also what they do
look like with that that very dominating
sort of lift here that's quite steep and
the crazy amount of supports and support
structures right in the middle of the
track and the track is kind of
interweaving and ducking over and
underneath its own track and finally
coming back with that very small closer
to ground section and hopping into the
brake runs just like that it does break
a little bit much with those trims
though that's something I might want to
look at same goes for the trims at the
top but then again those trims and block
breaks can also help you get the pacing
of the track right without having to
actually edit the track itself but I'll
definitely slow down these strings at
the end a little bit
they shouldn't be really slowing down
the coaster to the speed that we
have it roll into the station with so
the time has come to write this crazy
thing and something I do in a note is
that these things very often seem
unsmooth on POV camera because of the
way that the camera moves around in
planet coaster to anticipate curves just
like they're on the drop so it can seem
very unsmooth even if parts of the track
are some weapon smooth just by how small
the track moves around it is quite hard
to make these seem like a very smooth
track in the game but anyway the speed
over here is just about kind of what
we're looking for a little bit slow
maybe in parts like this but it usually
does have layout which is very slow on
those top parts where does the weird
things like having the hang time in the
diving loop or having the outside banked
curves and having those dips in the
middle of the track where it goes to the
ground and make some speed and yeah
that's basically the very standard kind
of SNS el loco kind of layouts a couple
of interesting trivia now that I'm busy
with this anyway I have this is really
just about what you want to do for these
courses and there are different ways
that you can just you know use your
creativity on these things because they
have such weird elements but this kind
of fits into my earlier arrow kind of
episodes which I had before because as
an S which is the company that makes
these things which I just accidentally
named dropped but it's actually a
company that bought the rights to all of
the assets I believe all of them from
arrow after they went bankrupt so it's
kind of the legacy of arrow as well and
they have also built the 40 courses that
arrow has built as well that's probably
material for a later episode but it's
quite interesting and also there is
actually a 7th el loco goes through
which not that many people know about
and it's analog which I believe was only
open for a couple of hours
it was built in Tokyo and it was
terrible it was actually built by the
Japanese branch of the company or
actually a company in which bought the
entire as an S Company
and it didn't turn out all that well
even if it had some that classical
a local kind of traits to it so these
things as weird and small and quirky as
they may be are actually some very
well-respected coasters with some very
interesting elements and provide a very
thrilling experience on a very small
part of ground and even for a very low
price so they're really one of my
favorites I would love to ride one of
these someday it's definitely on my
bucket list to do it and yeah this is
basically one of the Ilocos also by the
way interesting trivia as well this is
actually not the standard el loco car
these are the extra-large ones which I
believe were originally used for the
Green Lantern coaster and they're kind
of seen as the standard al local cars in
the game now but the standard el loco
car is actually even smaller than these
ones so they are really really small
quirky coasters
anyway that's probably enough long
coaster ends for me for today I hope you
guys enjoyed this episode and learn
something from it
and I'll see you in the next video